[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره بدا الناخبون الاتراك قبل ساعه
التصويت في اطار الجوله الثانيه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه وستستمر عمليه
التصويت حتى الساعه الخامسه من مساء اليوم
في جميع ولايات التركيه وفي المعابر
الحدوديه والمطارات ويتنافسوا في هذه
الجوله الثانيه كل من الرئيس التركي
المرشحي عن تحالف الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان
وزعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري المرشحي عن
تحالف الشعب كمال
هذه صور مباشره المشاهدين من احد مراكز
الاختراع في مدينه اسطنبول
ينضم الي مراسله الجزيره من ازمير احمد
فال ولد الدين ومن ديار بكر وليد العطار
مرحبا بكما احمد فال كيف هو الاقبال وقد
انقضت ساعه الاولى
جدا حيث حضر الناس بكذابه واضحه عند
اللحظات الاولى لبدايه الاقتراع خاصه كبار
السن لاحظوا حضورا لافتا لكبار السن
والعجزه
وطبقات عمريه مختلفه لكن هذه الطبقه كانت
اللافته جدا حيث انه طيله 60 دقيقه
الماضيه كان هناك حضور مميز جدا طبعا انا
اتحدث اليك محمد من ثانويه وسط
ثانويه
كمال اتاتورك والرمزي هنا في هذه المدينه
مكتمله تماما حيث ان هذه المدينه تعتبر هي
المعقله الاساسيه هي قلعه حزب الشعب حيث
ان حزب الشعب يمتلك هنا دائما اغلبيه
مريحه في هذه المدينه وبالتالي هناك تركيز
واضح على هذه المدينه وعلى ضروره ان يفوز
فيها كمالك بالنسبه لحزب الشعب حيث ان
الايام الماضيه الحمله طيله الاسبوعيه
الماضيه ركزت هنا على فكره طريفه جدا وهي
ان هناك طبقه تمثل حوالي خمسه بالمئه صوتت
في الشوط الاول وهي من القوميين الاتراك
صوتت في الشوط الاول
يحاول كمالك
اقناع هذه هذه الشريحه للتصويت له في هذه
المرحله لدرجه انه خلال اخر تصريح له قبل
الصمت لانتخاب طلبه اما ان يصوتوا له واما
ان يبقى في المنازل في محاوله واضحه
لاقناعهم بالتصفيه خاصه اذا تذكرنا انه في
ازمير من هذه الطبقه خمسه في الدور الاول
لسنان اوغان نعم محمد تفضل شكرا لك احمد
ولد الدين وليد العطار من ديار بكر حدثنا
ايضا احمد عن ازمير الاقبال والخصوصيه
ماذا عن ديار بكر
نعم محمد نحن على راس الساعه الثانيه في
السباق الانتخابي لهذا اليوم الاقبال هنا
في هذا المقر الانتخابي الذي عشرين
صندوقا هادئ ولكنه متواصل من قبل ان تفتح
صناديق الاقتراع في الثامنه كانت العائلات
تنتظر كان هناك ايضا كما ذكر زميل احمد في
ازمير كبار سن كان هناك عجزه ممن يعني
ينبغي ان تتقنهم يفترض ان تتقلهم ظروفهم
الصحيه وكان هناك ايضا عائلات جاءت
باطفالها كما شاهدنا في الجوله الاولى
يتكرر المشهد مره اخرى ونحن في الساعه
الاولى او يعني او على مشارف الساعه
الثانيه لهذا السباق الانتخابي الذي تخوده
تركيا للمره الاولى يوجد هناك سباق عادي
نحن نتحدث عن ديار باكر التي يدعى
للانتخاب فيها مليون و144 الف ناخب تقريبا
بعد اضافه 200
ناخب ممن بلغوا الثامنه عشره في الاسبوعين
الماضيين هذان الاسبوعان لم يشهد حملات
دعائيه انتخابيه نظرا
الاحتشاد وراءك ملك الاشجار اوغلو اصبح
احتشاد ضروره او يمكن اعتباره احتشادا على
مضد رغبه في التغيير اكثر من رغبه في
كمالك الاشجار اوغلو نفسه وخاصه بعد ما
اقدم عليه من التحالف مع اليمين القومي
بقياده زعيم حزب الظفر هذه الساعه الثانيه
الاجواء معتدله الى الان لا تشهد امطارا
ولكنها غائمه ربما تشجع مزيد من الناخبين
في الساعات القادمه التي سنظل فيها في
المتابعه
للاقبال على الصناديق الاقتراع التي شهدت
نسبه تجاوز الثمانين في المئه في الجوله
الاولى ولكن طبعا كان هناك الحافز
البرلماني وكان هناك علو نفس الاحتشاد او
الدعوه للتصويت وكانت هناك حملات انتخابيه
اكثر بكثير من الجوله الثانيه محمد احمد
وليد العطار من ديار بكر واحمد ولد الدين
من ازمير شكرا جزيلا لكما بتاكيد سنلتقي
معكما بمعيه الزملاء المنتشرين في عموميات
تركيا لتغطيه هذا الحدث الانتخابي البارز
على شاشه الجزيره شكرا على متابعه هذا
الموجز والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله